muchas vacantes y pocos interesados como
muchos otros bares que operan en las
calles empedradas del distrito la latina
de madrid esta taberna está repleta de
turistas mar benny rodríguez su
propietaria se siente aliviada de tener
la casa llena después de que el cob y de
19 devastar a su negocio pero ahora
enfrenta a otro dolor de cabeza
encontrar mano de obra en la época
favorita para el turismo que aporta un
12% del producto interno bruto nacional
hay una crisis de camarera por todo lo
que hemos hablado de los salarios de las
horas tienen que echar de más pero es
que yo creo que la crisis es una crisis
estructural
de la economía y del trabajo en el no
solamente de la hostelería
los trabajadores atribuyen la escasez de
mano de obra a las precarias condiciones
es difícil pues yo creo que básicamente
es lo que se paga el sueldo
toda la reforma que hemos tenido desde
hace muchos años en la cual se han
perdido derechos y claro se trabaja
mucho y se cobra poco según datos del
ministerio de trabajo españa registró en
junio la cifra nunca antes vista de 20,3
millones de cotizantes a la seguridad
social mientras que los cerca de 29
millones de desocupados representan el
registro más bajo desde la crisis
financiera de 2008 sin embargo también
tiene la segunda tasa de desempleo
juvenil más alta de europa después de
grecia con tres de cada diez menores de
25 años por fuera del mercado laboral